qui apparaît que difficile c'est
effectivement consorts d'années et
d'années dans lesquelles les luttes
sociales ont perdu dans lesquels on n'a
fait que reculer du point de vue mais je
vous parle nos actions pour allonger
réalisme économique mais le réalisme
économique voit ce que ça dans quel dans
quel pays est ce que ça est-ce que ça
est ce que ça existe aujourd'hui dans
quel pays au moule à la question elle
est de savoir comment oussama l'un des
richesses jamais existé dans aucun pays
oui mais nulle part dans et mais dans le
même temps voire de l'humanité dans le
même temps les plus riches toujours plus
riches mais alors ici à la question
est-ce que je résilie des stones ou
impayés ou aujourd'hui 6ème temps
maintenant de passer non qui vous
inspire ce qui nous inspire c'est
effectivement un projet d'une société de
coopération d'une société de solidarité
d'une société de codécision et
d'autogouvernement ça c'est quelque
chose qui a été propre portée depuis le
début des mouvements des montres ça
exige une répartition des richesses
respecte absolument vous allez vous y
prendre parce que les riches ne sont pas
tellement envie de donner leur argent
c'est pour rouvroy c'est pour ça que je
veux faire un petit peu chez m c'est
pour ça que je vous dis que c'est une
question de rapport de force mais le
problème il n'est pas de l'existence de
la richesse huit hommes au monde possède
autant que la moitié la plus pauvre de
l'humanité on va dire que le problème il
n'est pas de la quantité de richesses
il est de la question de la répartition
et enée aussi mauvais et sam usher votre
programme comment vous allez financer
parce que je comprends bien ce que vous
dites c'est si c'est bon j'ai envie de
dire mais c est quoi
et que même au fait concrètement et nous
on a envie de poser les problèmes par le
bon bout et ne pas être prisonnier de
soi disant les marchés auxquels on ne
peut rien dire qu'il faut surtout pas
inquiété parce que les mariés sont là
les marchés faut faire un retrait
d'argent et qu'est ce qui est vraiment
important il faudrait parler à la
boutique ce qui est important mais pas
prisonnier aussi parfois d'une idéologie
qui ce n'est pas le mot égard même
philippe poutou parce qu'il sait plus
très bien ils chérissent emmêlé les
pinceaux lui même aller au bout notre
projet de société pression ce serait de
produire ce dont on a besoin
pas pour le gaspillage pas pour des
marchandises
aujourd'hui la production elle se fait
pas en fonction de ce qui est utile de
ce qui est nécessaire de ce qui est
écologiquement soutenable
il se fait en fonction de ce qu'ils
rapportent des profils